and I never used to be able to recognize
myself in mirrors my brain would expect
to see someone female staring back at me
but instead it saw someone that was male
[Music]
welcome everybody to this session uh my
name is Bobby Picard I am a global
diversity Equity the inclusion director
and also CEO of transmit city which is
the world's biggest corporate
collaboration for Trans awareness I'm
completely honored to be here actually
with the absolutely amazing Peter tachel
who I'm sure needs no introduction
um but I'm sure
um shares the love of of just about
everybody that I've come across in the
lgbtqia community I'm going to hand over
to Peter
um to start this session thanks thank
you
well it's great to be here
I want to tell you that we offered to
have a debate with a trans critic and
we're told that no trans critic was
willing to debate us
on Friday Catherine stock a trans critic
spoke here
alone
unchallenged with no trans person to
debate her
I just think it shows that the people
who demonize and vilify trans people
often don't have the guts
to put their views to public scrutiny
and to face challenge from people who
are trans who've lived the experience
I'm not trans but I am a trans Ally and
have been for over 50 years
but I'm also a supporter of women's
Liberation as well
you know women's rights are human rights
and I have supported hundreds of women's
rights campaigns over the last five
decades both here in the UK and
supporting women's struggles around the
world
so for me there can be no Liberation
without women's liberation
but equally for the same five decades
I've supported the trans struggle for
dignity respect and human rights I see
no contradiction between trans and
women's liberation there are two sides
of the same coin
both have my support
I in particular
Echo the views of many pro-trans
feminists these are feminists who also
believe that trans rights are compatible
with feminism
um I have opposed the transcritical
views of people like Kathleen stock and
others
but I want to say that I do urge and
then to the abuse and intimidation by
some people on both sides of this debate
that is not helpful we have to have this
debate in a rational way in my view we
have to change bigotry but threatening
people and abusing people is not the way
to go
um I've also got to say that as a trans
Ally trans people get the worst but as a
trans Ally I get threats as well I've
had threats from people who claim they
support feminism and oppose trans rights
I've had threats to have me killed
castrated and raped to have my home
burned down
now that to me is
Beyond The Pale but it's nothing by
comparison to what a lot of trans people
face which is why some trans people are
not willing to have these debates
because they fear the consequence of the
intimidation and threats of violence and
rape that they face
my starting point in this debate I
suppose is that biological sex is a fact
it's a reality
but so too is gender identity
both are real
biological sex and gender identity are
different
but they're equally valid
trans women are woman
but they're not the same as other women
they are different from biological women
but that difference is legitimate
it should be accepted and respected
so I respect both
biological woman and trans woman
Both Deserve respect dignity and rights
now a lot of the trans critics argue
that we have to maintain biological sex
as the dominant issue in this debate
they say that biological sex is the
basis on which women are oppressed
and that is partly true partly true
in large parts of the world however
women are also oppressed because they
don't conform to the way women are
supposed to dress
speak and act
in other words
women are oppressed because of their
gender non-conformity
not their biological sex per se
and this is very similar to the way in
which trans people are oppressed because
they don't conform to the expectations
that go with their biological sex in
other words trans people and many
biological women are both oppressed
because they don't conform to gender
roles and stereotypes transcritic
sometimes to me seem determined to
police and reinforce
a strict male female divide
rather than break down and overcome
those barriers and divisions
now I happen to think that a sex and
gender revolution would be a very good
thing
I think historically we've been putting
boxes male female masculine feminine
you're supposed to behave this way or
that way that has been so oppressive
it doesn't give an understanding or an
acceptance about individual diversity
I've been around so long that I was
involved in supporting the women's
Liberation movement in the early 1970s
and one of the battle cries of the
women's Liberation movement five decades
ago was biology is not destiny
but now some trans critics say
biology is Destiny
it's a complete reversal of what the
women's movement stood for five decades
ago
I think it's a very regressive step
um obviously biology is a reality
but progressives should be doing
everything in their power
to limit its adverse consequences for
both women and trans people
so as I said like many women many
feminists
I stand with trans people
I support protection for them
and for other women
it is totally right that we should be
concerned about women's safety that's an
absolute thing that we should all be
concerned about that's a valid valid
concern
but it doesn't require or Justify a
blanket exclusion of trans women from
women's spaces
the idea that all trans women should be
excluded from certain women's spaces
is based upon a preemptive assumption
in fact a form of punishment or
restriction
based on who trans people are
not what trans people have done
the transcript is saying because you are
trans regardless of what you've ever
done in your life you should be excluded
from these spaces
that's outrageous to punish and restrict
People based on an assumption of what
they might do or could do
now I've got friends who work in women's
centers around the country
and I know several that have accepted
trans women for in one case so far seven
years with the agreement of the staff
and with the women users
they tell me they have never had a
problem of trans people in their Women's
Center never had a problem at all
so again the idea that exclusion should
be the presumption which is what
transcritics are arguing for I think is
not backed up by the evidence
now these women's centers
that all women users
and they rightly exclude anyone
trans or not trans who acts in an
abusive threatening or harmful way
you know there is one woman set up where
they did have problems it was from a
biological woman
who was harassing other women in the
center for sex
wasn't a trans woman it was a biological
woman
and they dealt with that through the
normal protection procedures when it
comes to
the whole issue about toilets I mean you
know trans women have been using toilets
for decades without a problem no one has
noticed there's never been an issue but
now suddenly it's a big big issue
I mean many institutions from the
schools that I go to talk to to Pride
events and even to GB news which is not
exactly trans friendly they all have
gender neutral toilets
you go to a Pop Festival they're all
gender-neutral toilets no problem this
is a hypothetical scaremongering that
has no basis in fact because those
gender-neutral toilets have lockable
cubicles so the women who use them are
perfectly safe and secure
now obviously there are some exceptions
so
any person who claims to be a trans
woman but presents with a beard or
engages in sexual harassment or exposes
male genitals in women's spaces well
that's not on they should be ejected and
if they're engaged in harassment of
course they should be prosecuted
but so far I haven't heard of
I've only heard about two examples where
that's happened two examples out of
millions of instances around the world
people really are clutching at straw to
use this as an argument against trans
people
um sexual harassment and unwanted
genital exposure that could cause
offense is obviously wrong
it shouldn't be tolerated regardless of
whether it's perpetrated by by
biological woman or trans woman
however as I said
unacceptable trans Behavior
uh in toilets or women's changing rooms
has almost never happened there have
been a few instances but only as few
and it's totally unrepresentative of how
almost all trans women behave respecting
the dignity and sensitivity of other
women
so let's not exaggerate based on a
handful of examples where bad things
have been done
if we look at women on women violence
and sexual assault
much of it is perpetrated
not by trans women but by biological
women
so I can think of instances where
biological women have sexually harassed
or been violent towards other women
once again there may be a handful of
instances where trans women have done
this but in many cases it is biological
women who are doing the violence the
harassment and so on
so obviously any woman including trans
woman with a history of violent or
sexual offenses
against women
should not be placed in the general
population of a woman's prison
if they have us this history and record
of sexual or other violence they should
not be placed in the general population
the same as a biological wound a
biological woman who's a threat to other
women should not be placed in the
general prison population unless of
course there is clear evidence that they
have reformed and we need to hold out
the hope of redemption and reform to
those who have done bad things
but even then in a woman's prison
um
those people trans or biological women
should be subject to monitoring and
review as would happen in every other
case
you know when biological women do bad
things
they are put under Supervision in a
prison
um if there is
evidence that a trans woman is an
ongoing threat to other women
or a biological woman who's an ongoing
threat to other women they should
probably be placed in a separate unit
within a woman's prison
and they should not be permitted to mix
with the general woman's population
unless there is Staff supervision
and this is the policy that's already
adopted by many prisons anyway
and it doesn't just apply to trans women
applies to biological one who have been
guilty of violence or sexual assault
so what I'm trying to say is when it
comes to the prison issue
this is an example of how we can reach
an acceptable a way of dealing with
these practical problems
where we can deal with legitimate
concerns about women's welfare and
safety but not have blanket
discrimination against trans women
as I said it's very wrong to demonize
and exclude
trans Woman based on what a few may do
in the same way it's wrong to demonize
and exclude all Muslims because a tiny
handful are terrorists now no decent
person would say just because these
handful of tiny tiny handful of Muslims
are terrorists that we should have
restrictions on the whole Muslim
population
but some people are saying that same
thing when it comes to Trends because a
handful of done bad things all trans
women should be penalized I just don't
accept that because
most trans women
the vast majority of trans women are no
threat or danger to any woman
whatsoever
trans woman are not the enemy of other
women
the fight by some
feminists and some woman against trans
inclusion
is a huge distraction from the very
major inequalities and abuses that all
women including trans women are at risk
of
so we should be focusing on violence
against women including trans women rape
harassment domestic abuse unequal pay
lack of affordable child care
under representation in senior positions
in government and business and the
trafficking of women into sexual slavery
and domestic servitude
those are far bigger more damaging
issues and I just look now and see how
some feminists are putting so much
energy into this
trans issue to the neglect of these
other issues that really have a far
greater damaging impact upon women's
lives
um you know these are really serious
issues and they should be the focus
um I believe that we should all Stand
Together
whatever our biological sex or gender
identity
to oppose sexist injustices
as they affect women including trans
women
let's not divide and fight each other
it weakens both the trans movement and
the women's movement
the only people who gain from
transculture Wars are misogynists
transphobes religious conservatives and
the far right
all of whom back transcritical
campaigners
and that ought to be a really major
issue of concern when I post in support
of trans
people I get so much toxic hate I can
cope with it but I look at who's doing
it I click on them and their profile
these are people who are out and out
misogynists they're anti-immigrant
they're racist
they're homophobic they're just using
the trans debate created by some trans
feminists anti-trans feminists to
further their own extreme agenda
to me we have to fight both misogyny and
transphobia
unity and solidarity
together we are stronger and together we
all win thank you
[Applause]
what he said should we go and have an
early lunch
um
I said before I was really honored to be
here and I am really honored to be here
and you know I feel like I really
shouldn't be here and I shouldn't be
here actually because 48 of trans people
attempt suicide in their lifetime
85 percent have some form of depression
through their lives 92 percent have
suicide gladiation nine out of ten trans
people seriously consider taking their
own lives
and that's nothing to do with this being
trans
I've been trans all my life I came to
terms with being trans when I was about
six years old I've been perfectly fine
with it ever since
what those figures reflect is our
society not allowing trans people to be
themselves not allowing trans and
non-binary people to live their own
lives how they need to live how they
need to survive
if there's any other part of our society
that had anywhere near those figures
we'd be up in arms
and we'd be trying to figure out
why that was happening and trying to
resolve it
instead we're in a situation at the
moment
where the only voices being heard are
anti-trans people
coming up with hypothetical
scare-mongering stories and making the
situation worse
and that situation is being made worse
by online media it's being made worse by
print media it's being made worse by the
broadcast media
Peter gave a great example there
of this great trans debate there is no
real trans debate because the only
voices people are hearing are anti-trans
people
and we've seen people like Kathleen
stock have their own session
here at this Festival
just to say her point of view and she's
completely entitled to her point of view
I don't have a problem with her having
her own point of view
thank you
but I've seen four or five speakers
at this Festival
with anti-trans views
giving their points of views
the only trans person I've seen at this
Festival
is me and I'm here at the invitation of
Peter to speak
so there is no debate
there's just far right wing people and
anti-trans people talking about trans
people
when they know nothing about our lives
I like I said have been trans all of my
life being trans is a perfectly natural
thing
we've known we've seen the indications
now for
at least 70 years that it's caused by
hormonal development or hormonal
receptivity on the brain
it's as natural as being red-headed
actually it's about when you look
globally around about the same amount of
percentage of people that are redheaded
are trans
and all it means is that your biological
sex and your gender identity
in simplest possible terms the
biological sex the sex of your body
and your gender identity the sex of your
brain are different to each other
and if you're not trans and I know lots
of people don't like the term they don't
like the label cisgender is the
scientific term if you're not trans
um loads of people don't like labels and
I completely appreciate that I don't
like labels myself so if you're not
trans
and your biological sex and your gender
align
then you've probably never considered
that they could be two separate things
you'd probably never thought
that they could be different to each
other but they absolutely can and if
they are different to each other then
you feel the effect
and that affects that you feel that
gender dysphoria that stress that you
feel when you have your biological sex
is one thing and your gender identity as
another can be extreme
your body always wants to bring itself
into line with your brain you you know
it's nature nature always loves an
equilibrium
you can't change your brain but you can
change your body you can change how you
express yourself and you can alleviate
those feelings of gender dysphoria
and it's
easiest form for me different trans
people non-binary people experience
gender dysphoria in different ways
it's easiest form for me
gender dysphoria feels like that really
horrible sinking feeling that
something's gone wrong
you know you've gone through a speed
camera and it's flashed at you
or you've opened up an exam paper
and you've looked at all the questions
and you've realized that you can't
answer anything you know that really
horrible deep sinking horrible feeling
you know
that feeling the night before when
you're sitting in your motor home
thinking oh God I'm speaking in the Hat
tomorrow at 11 o'clock and I haven't got
the foggiest idea of what I'm going to
say that type of horrible thinking
feeling that's gender dysphoria at its
easiest
at its worst it's made me physically
sick it's made me shake it gives you
such a feeling of disassociation
you know we all have an internal vision
of Who We Are we all do we all hold that
we net within ourselves who we are as a
person
what we look like
our being
and I've had that all my life like
everybody else as well but as far as my
brain's concerned
I'm female so I used to get up in the
morning I used to wander into the
bathroom look in the bathroom mirror and
my brain would expect to see someone
female staring back at me but instead it
saw
someone that was male
and I never used to be able to recognize
myself in mirrors even to the point I
used to wander around
shopping centers
those big floor-to-ceiling shopping
center mirrors that you see in shopping
centers used to take me two or three
seconds
to try and guess who I was in the crowd
of people
mainly by you know the clothes that that
person was wearing
that not being able to recognize
yourself causes such disassociation
because when your brain doesn't receive
what it believes to be reality
then it assumes that you're dreaming it
assumes you're in a lucid dream
so it disassociates you from real life
you can't interact with people
you can't
make that societal connection with
people
because you're not really here
16th of September
2016 after
35 years of suicide gladiation and lots
of attempts
I found myself standing at the side of a
road in Crawley on a humpback Bridge
um on a blind Bend where um
loads of huge huge typologies you know
there's really massive ones were coming
to and from
a waste disposal site I used to work in
the most lovely areas
um
and I just decided that I'd had enough
that pressure that's put on You by
society and that pressure that you put
on you yourself because you can't bring
yourself into equilibrium
was too much
and I stepped out in front of one Lorry
and just got the timing wrong
and the wing mirror clipped the the
front of my hair
and I was going to step out in front of
the next lorry
when I realized I hadn't written the
songs out that I wanted for my funeral
and I'm a musician I've always been a
musician
and that was so important to me I just
wanted that one bit of my life to be me
to reflect the real me
to be the one bit
of all of that 48 years of life where I
could have said here I am
and I stood at that road for a while and
decided to go home and write out
the list of songs
and come back the next day
and I got halfway home and I heard a
song on the radio and that
I think made me angry enough
to want to carry on and that gave me an
extra day and then an extra week and an
extra month then after about nine months
I decided finally
that I was going to transition
or actually the choice I had was either
to get on and kill myself or try to
transition
and I decided that I may as well try
transitioning
because if it didn't work I could always
kill myself afterwards
so
I did transition finally and there's a
whole story around transitioning there
you know transitioning isn't just
medical transitioning because of that
alignment that adjusting of the
equilibrium that trans people always do
they're always transitioning to some
extent but I medically transitioned came
out finally to the last few people that
that didn't know and it was the best
thing I'd ever done
I went from having a bleak existence
with no color in the world to seeing
every single color on every single blade
of grass and flower
I get such Joy from the world
just by being in it
just by interacting with people I used
to be a person that couldn't walk into a
room of more than two or three people
because I was forever trying to hide who
I was and now
I can stand on stage sit on stage
and talk to people like you
I can enjoy life
this is what you give trans people when
you allow them to be trans when you
allow them to transition you don't give
them back their life you give them life
you give them color you give them Joy
you allow them to flourish and isn't
that
that flourishing in our life
isn't that what we all want isn't that
what we want for ourselves isn't that
what we want for other people
isn't that what every single person
in our society in the world deserves
Peter's so very eloquently given us the
facts to debunk the myth
the real myth is that trans people are a
problem
we're not we just want to live we just
want to flourish
we just want to be part of the same
society that you are thank you
[Applause]
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV